September
2022 Iran a movement was
born people took to the streets across
the country to fight for the fundamental
rights of women Liberty equality
democracy the European Parliament stood
with them calling for sanctions against
the Iranian regime and continues to do
so by awarding the 2023 sacharov prize
to the woman life Freedom Movement and
Gina Masa
amini I think Massa Gina's name become a
symbol of resistance of uh of demanding
Justice and recognizing suffering of
women's inside of Iran amini was a young
Kurdish woman she was arrested by Iran's
morality police her crime incorrectly
wearing her hijab she was beaten and
tortured 3 days later she died Ida haar
in Exile in France since 2010 broke
amini's story it was so hard it was uh
in my head every day after that day and
put me in situation that feel more and
more
responsibility not just about her about
our mission as a journalist amini's
death sparked massive protests led by
women in Iran and around the world women
life Freedom Iranian authorities
responded with astonishing brutality
tens of thousands were arrested hundreds
killed including children many people
were deliberately
blinded
for despite the violent repression
Iranians continued to
demonstrate
let's today prize serve as our tribute
to the Brave and defiant women men and
young people in Iran who despite coming
under increasing pressure are leading
the push for change the European
Parliament hears you the world sees you
and we are with you Zan zendi
[Applause]
o